yes it's oxford high school 45 miles
north of detroit in michigan
and the shooting took place about two
and a half hours ago one o'clock lunch
time local time in michigan and
there are as you say reports of three
people having been killed all three of
those people are said to be students
six others injured including one teacher
and um
the person firing the shots has been
taken into custody and we are told that
he is a or they that person is a 15 year
old
student themselves so a very very
difficult situation in this school
oxford high school 45 miles north of
detroit a high school that has some 1
600 students so a big
school
michigan itself is an open carry state
so guns are a common sight not in
schools but certainly across the state
although you have to be 18
to uh to be allowed to have a gun uh we
had an update a short while ago from the
local sheriff have a listen
the
deputies uh took a suspect into custody
within five minutes of the original
recovered a 911 from the suspect the
suspect fired multiple shots there's
multiple victims
it's unfortunate i have to report that
we have three deceased victims right now
who are all believed to be students we
have six others that were shot one was a
schoolteacher they're all local
hospitals being treated for various
injuries
to give you a sense of the chaos that
must have unfolded a few hours ago at
that school there were hundred nine one
one calls made uh within the space of
just a few minutes imagine the chaos
both at the school and at the
switchboard as they took in those calls
and tried to work out what was going on
as we understand it they are still
looking in the school to see whether
there are any other victims but but as i
said three
students have died as a consequence of
this six other people including one
teacher
are injured the suspect is in custody i
have to say
it's a grim reality of
of this country that school shootings
do happen uh we've reported on them so
many times before although recently over
the course of the past 18 months they
haven't been quite so common that the
reason for that of course is that
students have been at home
homeschooling because of um coronavirus
but they are largely now back in schools
and we are seeing once again this this
awful uh thing that happens so many
times in america once again three
students dead